most often my work begins with my
trajectories through the city
I never choose an audience I realized
that I'm I am a part of that audience
and I try to look towards how I am
participating in a given community or
participating in a situation how my own
my presence is activated and what it
does to the situation how I'm involved
in whatever exchange is occurring and I
think when I realized that I'm a part of
a group then I think that's really when
the work begins often from observations
of repeated passes through an area I
start to notice the the landscape a
little more detailed and nuanced and
from that point I think the work starts
to to take hold and so there's never
really an audience that's chosen as much
as a realization that I'm a part of this
audience and I also receive the benefits
of whatever sort of charity occurs
through the work I think that's
important for me to to be a part of it
you